[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليال اختيار استهلها بابراز
العناوين
بسبب الخلافات بين الدعم السريع والجيش
تاجيل توقيع الاتفاق النهائي في السودان
بعد يوم هادئ عوده الاحتجاجات الى فرنسا
تمديدا بعنف الشرطه تجاه المتظاهرين مؤخرا
الخارجيه الروسيه تتهم مراسل
بالجاسوسيه والصحيفه تعتبرها ازمه
دبلوماسيه
بعد استثمارات له بالمليارات ايلون ماسك
يطالب بايقاف تطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي حفظا
للوظائف
[موسيقى]
ازمه السودان مستمره وترقب لتوقيع اتفاق
نهائي بين المكونات السياسيه والعسكريه
لاعاده الاستقرار الى البلاد الا ان
الموعد المحدد للاتفاق تم تاجيله التفاصيل
مشاهدينا في سياق التاسعه
[موسيقى]
اذا افادت مراسله العربيه بتاجيل توقيع
الاتفاق النهائي في السودان المقرر في
الاول من ابريل المقبل بسبب الخلافات حول
دمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش الا ان
مصادر مطلعه كشفت للعربيه عن اجتماعات
مرتقبه لاحتواء تلك الخلافات حول اليه
وجدول الزمني لدمج قوات الدعم السريع في
صفوف القوات المسلحه ياتي ذلك رغم تاكيد
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في وقت سابق
التزامها بالوصول لجيش قوي مهني واحد وبكل
ما ورد في الاتفاق السياسي الايطالي
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم الفريق فتح الرحمن
محي الدين المحلل العسكري استاذ يعني
الخلاف حول التفاصيل الاساسيه لعمليه دمج
هذه القوات بالجيش والتي هي بصلب العمليه
الانتقاليه العسكريه اليوم في السودان ما
هو الخلاف اليوم الذي حال دون توقيع هذا
الاتفاق
الساده المشاهدين ورمضان كريم وشكرا على
الاستضافه انا اعتقد انه ورشه الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري بلمس تم يعني ختامها
بطريقه غير لايقه يعني كان ينبغي ان
ينتظروا ان تكتمل المشاورات في اليه
توقيتات ومراحل دمج الدعم السريع في
القوات المسلحه ولكنهم استعجلوا ان ينهوا
هذه الورشه بهذا الشكل الذي لا يفضي الى
شيء وطبعا بالتاكيد هذا الله يرضي القوات
المسلحه ولن تقبل به واتم المسلحه تتحدث
عن ضروره وجود جيش وطني واحد في الفتره
الانتقاليه كي يحمل فتره الانتقاليه وكي
يضمن الوصول الى انتخابات حره ونزيهه
وبالتالي اهم ما في هذا الامر ان تكون
هنالك مواقيت محدده قطعيا في التوصيات
ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري في كيف
تكمل عمليات دمج الدعم السريع في المسلحه
ولكنهم حتى الان اللي جان الفنيه لم تصل
الى توافق حول هذه التوقيتات وبالتالي
يعني كان من الافضل لهم بلمسه ان لا
يعقدوا الجلسه الختاميه ان تؤجل هذه
الجلسه الى حين اكتمال التوافق حول
توقيتات دمج الدعم السريع في القوات
المسلحه ومن ثم تصدر التوصيات كامله
وتختتم الورشه هكذا يعني بطريقه يعني
مفيده لكن للاسف الذين ينظم هذه الورث
يزعم دائما الى ان تكون هذه الورشه
الشكليه وصوريه وهم يستعجلون دائما
نتائجها تابعنا كل الورش يعني تحدثوا عن
ورشه اتفاق السلام دون حضور معظم الذين
وقعوا اتفاق السلام تحدثوا عن ورشه شرق
السودان دون حضور معظم القيادات الفاعله
في الشرق السودان تحدي هكذا كله ورشهم
كانت صوريه وشكليه
اليوم حول هذه الورشه التي نتحدث عنها حول
توحيد القوى العسكريه التي تاتي يعني في
صلب الاطار
الاتفاق الايطالي هل هي ورشه صواريه ولا
يمكن يعني ان تراقب الصدع الموجود بين
الفريقين خصوصا ان الخلافات كبيره يعني
حول موضوع كيفيه الانضمام والانتقال وكل
الملفات الاخرى الموجوده
شوف يعني السيد رئيس مجلس السياده منذ
فتره تحدث عن ان احد الاسباب الرئيسيه
التي دعت القوات المسلحه للمضي قدما في
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي هو دمج الدعم السريع
داخل القوات المسلحه وبالتالي اصبح هذا
امرا جوهريا ضروريا لا يمكن تجاوزه باي
شكل من الاشكال كان من المهم جدا ان تنصب
كل الجهود للتوفيق فيما بين اطراف اللجنه
التي تحكم الان على ان تحدد توقيتات لدمج
الدعم السريع داخل القوات المسلحه كان
ينبغي
للجهاد
المسهله ان تبذل جهده توفق ما بيناتهم في
هذه التوقيتات الى ان نصل الى توقيتات
مرضيه للقوات المسلحه لانه القوات المسلحه
لن ترضى بان يكون الدعم السريع خارج
سيطرتها خلال الفتره الانتقاليه وهم حقيقه
هناك يعني الكثير من التسريبات وتصريحات
بان الجيش غير راضي عن الورقه التي قدمها
الدعم السريع حول عمليه الانتقال الى
الجيش ابقى معنا لو سمحت
مشاهدينا قال هنا رئيس دائره الاعلام في
حزب الامه القوميه السودانيه والقيادي
للقوى الحريه والتغيير مصباح احمد قال انه
لا يوجد اي تاجيل حتى الان لتوقيع الاتفاق
السياسي النهائي في الاول من ابريل
حتى الان ليس هنالك تاجيل
التوقيعه الاتفاق النهائي في الاول من
ابريل حتى هذه اللحظه بالامس اجتماع الامس
اكد على على الالتزام كل الاطراف
بالمضيب العمليه السياسيه الى نهايتها
والالتزام بالمواقيت الزمنيه التي اتفق
عليها في 15 مارس للمنصرين
اليك الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين المحلل
العسكري من الخرطوم هل استمعت الى التصريح
الذي عرضناه بان لا تاجيل وبان الاتفاق
سيتم على اي اساس مبني هذا التصريح وهل
فعلا يعني هناك امال بان يتم التوقيع
انا اعتقد هذا التصريح مبني من منطلق يعني
ظلوا يعني ينطلقون منه دائما هو استعجالهم
الى الوصول الى السلطه استعجالهم الى ان
تمضي الامور هكذا شكليا حتى المراحل بتاعه
التوقيع التي يتحدثوا عنها في في الاول من
ابريل والسادس والحادي عشر ايضا هذه انا
اعتقد انها توقيتات متعجله جدا هم يزرعوا
حسيسين لكي يصلوا الى السلطه انا لا اعتقد
هنالك منطق يجعل المكون العسكري يوقع في
الاول من يناير ان لم يكتمل اللجنه الفنيه
المعنيه بتحديد توقيتات الدمج السريعه في
القوات المسلحه
هذا امر جوهري اذا تم يمكن ان يكون
التوقيع في الاول من يناير
امامنا فرصه يوم الغد اذا توافقت هذه
اللجنه توصلت الى توقيتات سليمه تضمن دمج
الدعم السريع داخل اللغات المسلحه يمكن ان
يكون التوقيفه الاول لكن ان لم يكن ذلك
انا لا اعتقد ان هنالك معنى للتوخيه حتى
يتم التوقيع انا اعتقد انه لا معنى له
ممكن ان يوقعوا منفردين دون القوات
المسلحه ولكن ماذا يعني ذلك
خصوصا اليوم ان لدى القوات المسلحه نعم
بحسب التسريبات حاله عدم يقين بالتوقيت
وبالاليه
لضم قوات الدعم السريع الى الجيش هذا ماذا
يعني واذا فعلا ذهبوا الى توقيع بدون يعني
وجود المؤسسه العسكريه ورضاها على كل
التفاصيل والورقه التي قدمت ماذا يعني
باختصار لو سمحت
هم حتى الاتفاق
الايطاليات المسلحه اذا كانت ما وقعت على
الاتفاق الايطالي لم تكن للاتفاق اي قيمه
قيمه العمليه السياسيه هذه كلها في القوات
المسلحه هم يعلمون ذلك يقينا ولكنهم يدعون
الاستعباط احيانا ان الممكن ان نمضي من
غير القوات المسلحه فليجربوا من غير
القوات المسلحه
ان شاء الله لكن انا اعتقد ان هذا كله
يسير من باب العبس والتهديد وليس عمل
سياسيا حكيما شكرا لك من الخرطوم الفريق
فتح الرحمن محي الدين المحلل العسكري
حدثتنا عن هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
في فرنسا الحراك الاحتجاجي يواصل مسيرته
رغم القمح حيث انطلقت منذ قليل تظاهره غير
مرخصه في باريس من قبل جمعيات ومنظمات
شبابيه تحمل شعارات تدين عنف الشرطه بعد
انتهاكات كثيره وسقتها الجمعيات الحقوقيه
وعدسات الكاميرا بحق المتظاهرين الرافدين
لنظام التقاعد الجديد وقبل ساعات مشاهدينا
من انطلاق التظاهرات دعا الرئيس
الفرنسيين الى التهدئه مشيرا الى ان
المجلس الدستوري سيفحص نص قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد بحكمه وهدوء واضاف ان الحوار
مستمر بين الحكومه والنقابات التي لها
الحق في التعبير عن رايها من خلال
التظاهرات بعيدا طبعا عن اعمال التخريب
ومشاهد العنف
هذا وتشهد فرنسا اجراءات امنيه مشدده خوفا
من تسجيل اي من تجاوزات مع دخول شباب
المعاهد والجامعات في الحركه الاحتجاجيه
التي لا تزال متواصله على تمرير قانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد مع مواصله يعني
الاصرار الرسمي على هذا القانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد الرئيس الفرنسي يصر على
فرضه بدون اي وساطه مع النقابات العماليه
فلنتابعه
اتمنى الملوك والاستياء في الشارع الفرنسي
لا يزالان متواصلين لينذلا بالمزيد من
الهزات السياسيه والاضطرابات الاجتماعيه
بعد تمرير اصلاح نظام التقاعد المعارضه
تسعى لاسقاط القانون ومعه الحكومه بعد ان
اخفق نوابها في الجمعيه الوطنيه الفرنسيه
في حجب الثقه عنها مساعي المعارضه رافقتها
اتهامات تشكك في شرعيه الرئيس الفرنسي
الذي بات مستقبله على المحك اتهامات قد
تدخل البلاد في ازمه حكم هي الاولى في
تاريخ فرنسا
الى تسعه اصوات لحجب الثقه وكسر هذه
الحكومه واصلاحها الحكومه ميته بالفعل في
اعين الشعب الفرنسي ولم تعد تتمتع
بالشرعيه
كذلك كان لها راي اخر حيث اتهمت رئيس
الفرنسي بالفشل الذريع غير ان ماكرون رد
بطريقه ضغط عليها الدبلوماسيه
اقول لك بمسؤوليه انا لا اتطلع الى اعاده
انتخابي لا يمكنني دستوريا لكن بين
استطلاعات الراي والمدى القصير والمصلحه
العامه للبلاد اختار المصلحه العامه
للبلاد وسائل الاعلام المحليه وحتى
الغربيه اعطت اهميه كبيره لما يحدث في
فرنسا منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات الرافضه لهذا
الاصلاح صحيفه لوبينيون الفرنسيه المحسوبه
على الليبراليين اكدت ان الازمه قد تتفاقم
والحكومه ستتعرض لخسائر كبيره مجله
انتقدت كل الكتل الحزبيه اليسريه وحتى
اليمينيه في تعاملها مع هذا القانون ووصفت
حكومه المتعثره اما صحيفه قالت بان ماكرون
يتعمد بشكل اقل او يعتمد بشكل اقل على
مؤسسات الدوله لفك الجمود وهو ما تسبب في
انقسام ديمقراطي اما صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
اشارت في وقت سابق الى ان الرئيس الفرنسي
في حاله ضعف وبات اكثر عزله وهو في وضع لا
يحسد عليه اما صحيفه الديل التليجراف
فوصفت ماكرون بالبطه العرجاء وبانه لم يعد
قادرا على الحكم في اشاره الى حاله من
الانهيار الديمقراطي في فرنسا في حين
اشارت وسائل اعلام المانيه الى ان ماكرون
تحدى الشعب والبرلمان في نفس الوقت بتمرير
قانون الاصلاح
للحديث اكثر مشاهدينا عن الوضع في
الباريزي ينضم الينا فادي مراسل العربيه
فادي يعني هذه التظاهره المحدوده نوعا ما
بانتظار التظاهره الكبيره
بالتحرك الكبير بالسادس من اي برول كيف هي
الصوره من هناك وما هي ابرز يعني مطالب
المتظاهرين التي اصبحت معروفه طبعا
مساء الخير ليال نعم هذه هي تظاهره محدوده
كما قلت لكن هذه التظاهرات المحدوده هي
التظاهرات الاكثر تاثيرا خلال او منذ
اسابيع لانها من تنظيم الطلاب وشريحه
الشباب يقومون بهذه التظاهرات من دون طلب
ترخيص لها من قبل الشرطه ويجبون في
الشوارع ثم تبدا الاشتباكات الان الاجواء
ما زالت هادئه وهذه التظاهره بالتحديد هي
ضد عنف الشرطه هؤلاء يدينون عنف الشرطه
المفرط الذي استخدم بحق المتظاهرين خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه طبعا كان هناك تحقيقات
فتحت بحق عدد من عناصر الشرطه وايضا كان
هناك انتقادات كثيره وجهت لوزير الداخليه
الذي يعتبر المسؤول الاول عن جهاز الشرطه
في فرنسا خصوصا وان هناك مقاطع مصوره
كثيره نشرت على وسائل الاعلام تظهر تدخلا
عنيفا من قبل قوات الشرطه في عمليات
الاعتقال وايضا في الاعتداء على صحفيين
كانوا فقط يحاولون تغط يه ما يحدث هذه
الدعوات او الانتقادات لوزير الداخليه
وصلت الى حد الطلب بحل احد اجهزه الشرطه
ويسمى البراف ام وهي القوه للتدخل السريع
على درجات الناريه هي التي ترتكب هذه
التجاوزات بشكل عام هذه الدعوه كانت من
قوه اليسار وخصوصا من قبل زعيم اليسار
الراديكالي جون ميلانشون
فادي يعني بموازاه هذه الروايه والروايات
المتظاهرين هناك ايضا روايه يعني روايه
للشرطه بانها تتعرض للاعتداء من قبل
المتظاهرين حينما يجبون بهذه التظاهرات
كيف يرى الشارع الفرنسي هذه العمليات
المواجهه بين المتظاهرين والشرطه
هناك ادانه للعنف من جميع الاطراف هذا ما
يحرص عليه الجميع في فرنسا وخصوصا الاحزاب
السياسيه لكن شريحه الشباب ترفض ان تتهم
بانها من تبدا العنف لانها كل ما تقوم به
هي التظاهر ومن ثم تبدا الاشتباكات مع
الشرطه بمجرد ان يحصل او بمجرد ان تقوم
الشرطه بمنع احد المواكب التي تسير في
شوارع العاصمه طبعا الشرطه ايضا استخدمت
سياسه جديده في منع هذه التظاهرات الصغيره
التي يقوم بها الطلاب والشباب من خلال نصب
كمائر وهذه اساليب ممنوعه في فرنسا
بالقانون لذلك هم يعتبرون ان الشرطه هي من
تبدا العنف
ويقومون برشقها بالمقابل بالحجاره عندما
تستخدم الشرطه الغاز المسيل للدموع طبعا
وقعت اصابات كثيره في صفوف قوات الشرطه
لكن النسبه الاكبر ما زالت في صفوف
المتظاهرين وخصوصا بالاضافه الى اعداد
الاصابات عدد المعتقلين خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه تجاوز عدد المعتقلين الال وهو رقم
قياسي في فرنسا كان استدعى قلقا وتصريحات
من عدد كبير من المحامين والقضاه الذين
اعلنوا ان المساله او ان الاوضاع تسير الى
الى مسار غير محمود وقد يكون هناك تصعيد
اكبر بكثير اعربوا عن قلقهم من حالات
الاعتقال هذه
يعني من الجانب الاخر المفاوضات الدائره
بين النقابات والحكومه هل من جديد فيها
خصوصا ان هناك اجتماع سيعقد كما هو معلوم
الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]
نعم هناك اجتماع سوف يعقد قبل الموعد
المقبل للتظاهرات والاضراب الذي دعت اليه
النقابات في السادس من شهر ابريل لكن هذا
الموعد حتى الان هو جاء بموافقه معظم
النقابات ما عدا نقابه او الكونفدراليه
العامه للعمل ما زالت لم تحسم امرها لانها
الان تخوض انتخابات لاختيار
رئيسها الجديد وهناك تنازع شديد في مساله
العنف تجاه او اتجاه المفاوضات البعض يريد
هناك جناحان احدهما يريد التفاوض مع
الحكومه والاخر يرفض كل اشكال التفاوض
والالتقاء مع رئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث
وايضا مع الرئيس ماكرون لذلك المساله ما
زالت غير واضحه تماما ربما هذا سوف يبدا
باثاره الانقسامات في صفوف النقابات لكن
حتى الان معظم النقابات اعلنت انها سوف
تتوجه للقاء رئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث في
الخامس من شهر ابريل شكرا لك فادي مراسل
العربيه حدثتنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا سانتقل الى اسرائيل وهذه
التظاهره المؤيده لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو والمدافعه عن موقفه في مساله
التعديلات القضائيه اذا انطلقت تظاهره
هناك تؤيد موقف نتنياهو هذه التظاهره طبعا
تاتي بعد دعوات اليمين والمعسكر الداعم
لنتنياهو بضروره النزول ايضا الى الشارع
بوجه التظاهرات الاخرى التي لم تهدا منذ
ان اعلن نتانيا عن خطته الراميه لاجراء
تعديلات قضائيه سنستمع قليلا واعود
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا هذه التظاهره التي انطلقت بعد الضغط
الداخلي والضغط الخارجي من قبل الولايات
المتحده من قبل الدول الاوروبيه على
نتنياهو للعدول عن موضوع التعديلات
القضائيه هو طبعا كما استمعنا بخطابه
الاخير ارجى وارجل هذا الاشكال السياسي
والقانوني الا ان يعني تمرير ما زال امر
وارد الكل يراهن على تراجع نتنياهو عن هذه
التعديلات التي اثرت على الداخل
الاسرائيلي واحد كبير داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي في الداخل وفي الخارج طبعا
التاسعه مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
بعد اعتقال اعتقال صحفي وصفي جورنال البيت
الابيض يدعو المواطنين الامريكيين لمغادره
روسيا فورا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تاكدت الخارجيه الروسيه
ان توقيش مراسل صحيفه
الى ان ما كان يفعله ليس له علاقه
بالصحافه وقالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان مراسل وستريد ضبط
متلبسا بالجرم المشهود اثناء التسريب
معلومات عن احدى المجتمعات الصناعيه
العسكريه الروسيه واستخدموا تصريحه
واعتماد الصحيفه طبعا كغطاء لانشطه غير
صحفيه
تصعيد اخر على جبهه اخرى بين موسكو واشنطن
جهاز الامن الاتحادي الروسي يعتقل صحفيا
امريكيا من اصل روسي يعمل مراسلا لصحيفه
وولز جورنال الامريكيه اما التهمه فهي
الاشتباه في قيامه بالتجسس لمصلحه واشنطن
الامن الروسي قال ان ايفان جريشكوفيتش كان
مكلفا من امريكا بجمع معلومات عن انشطه
احدى المؤسسات الدفاعيه غير ان بيان جهاز
الامن الروسي لم يقدم دليلا على الاتهامات
صحيفه وول ستريت جورنا نفت ما وصفتها
بالمزاعم الروسيه الموجهه لمراسلها واكدت
انها تسعى لاطلاق سراحه فورا
لكن الخارجيه الروسيه التي تعترف
بجريشكوفيتش مراسلا معتمدا في روسيا قالت
انما كان يفعله لا علاقه له بالصحافه
الكرملين من جانبه قال ايضا ان مراسل وول
ستريت جورنال ضبط متلبسا بالتجسس وملفه
بيد الامن الفيدرالي
موسكو استبعدت اي تبادل لجيرش كوفيتش مع
واشنطن واكدت ان ذلك ليس على جدول اعمالها
ولن يحدث ذلك قبل محاكمته جرش كوفيتش اول
صحفي امريكي يقبض عليه في روسيا بتهمه
التجسس منذ الحرب البارده وابرز شخصيه
امريكيه تعتقلها روسيا بعد نجمه كره السله
العام الماضي حيث قبض عليها في مطار موسكو
وبحوزتها زيت الحشيش اطلق سراحها في صفقه
لتبادل السجناء بين البلدين في ديسمبر
الماضي
وفي اول رد فعل رسمي امريكي على احتجاز
الصحافه الامريكيه
ايفانش في روسيا بتهمه التجسس دعا البيت
الابيض المواطنين الامريكيين على مغادره
الى مغادره روسيا فورا وعدم السفر اليها
واوضح البيت الابيض ان اداره بايدن تواصلت
مع عائله مراسل صحيفه وكذلك الحكومه
الروسيه اضافت بان اداره بايدن تحدثت مع
المسؤولين في الصحيفه حول ظروف احتجاز
الصحفيه الامريكي بدوره دان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينك ان احتجاز الصحافه
الامريكي وما وصفه بمحاولات الكرملين
المستمره لقمع الصحفيين ومعاقبتهم على حد
قوله كما اعرب بلينكن عن قلق واشنطن من
احتجازه مجددا التحذير بشان الخطر الذي
يتعرض له الامريكيون في روسيا على حد
تعبيره
ايفان قرش كوفيتش صحفي امريكي روسي الاصل
يتقن اللغه الروسيه يبلغ من العمر 31 عاما
ووالداهم مقيمان في الولايات المتحده منذ
مراسل يغطي روسيا واوكرانيا لدى صحيفه
وولد جورنال الامريكيه كان مراسلا لوكاله
قبل 2022
عمل كصحفيا في صحيفه موسكو تايمز الصادره
بالانجليزيه في 2017 اول مراسل بوسيله
اعلام امريكيه يعتقل بتهمه التجسس في
روسيا منذ الحرب البارده اعتقل في مدينه
كاترينبورج بجبال الاورال متورط في جمع
معلومات سريه بحسب وكاله الاستخبارات
الروسيه قررت محكمه روسيه حجزه لمده شهرين
على ذمه التحقيق بتهمه التجسس
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا من
واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي مديره مكتب العربيه
ناديه يعني امام ضغط الصحافه الامريكيه
اليوم على الرئيس بايدن وعلى الاداره
الامريكيه كيف سيتصرف البيت الابيض وهل
نتوقع اي تصعيد بالساعات المقبله
اهلا بك ليال اولا الرئيس بايدن والبيت
الابيض وزاره الخارجيه تعتبر بانه هذه
اتهامات باطله ضد صحفي
ان هذه التصريحات غير مقبوله على الاطلاق
وهناك ايضا اعضاء من الكونغرس الذين ذهبوا
الى حد وصف هذا الاعتقال بانه خطف لمواطن
امريكي وقالوا بانها عمليه اخذ
رهائن وبانها مقايده ربما على اساس ان
روسيا ستستخدمها لاحقا في الافراج على
مواطنين امريكيين روس معتقلين في الولايات
المتحده ومن هنا ترى بانه ايفن كان قد حصل
على تصريح للعمل في روسيا وان هذه
الادعاءات هي غير صحيحه على الاطلاق وغير
مقبوله وطبعا الرئيس بايدن علم باعتقاله
ليله امس وهو على اتصال بالقنصليه
الامريكيه في موسكو في محاوله لمعرفه
معلومات اكثر ورب ايصال هذه المعلومات
لعائلته لكن البيره بانه في اجواء التوتر
بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا بسبب حرب
اوكرانيا سيتم اعتقال صحفيين امريكيين ومن
هنا دعت وزاره الخارجيه كل المواطنين
الامريكيين الى مغادره روسيا طبعا وكما
تعرفين قبل حوالي عام كان هناك قرار روسي
يقضي بانه او يفضي لان كل صحفي يتحدث عن
هجوم على اوكرانيا او غزو روسي على
اوكرانيا يمكن ان يحاكم بتجريمه او يعني
توجه اليه تهم بانه يرتكب جريمه ومن هناك
ربما نقي الى الصحفيين الامريكيين على
العمل في روسيا لكن وجود ايضا طبعا الان
يدل على انه مره اخرى من حسب بحسب وجه
واشنطن بان هناك بالفعل استغلال لوجود
الصحفيين الذين يقومون بعملهم ما تتحدثين
عنه ناديه
تتحدث ين عنه الاستغلال لوجود الصحفيين
هناك اليوم يعني القاء القبض على صحافه هي
اقوى رساله ممكن ان توجه للبيت الابيض بعد
يعني بدا الحرب القضائيه بعد الحرب
السياسيه والحرب طبعا على الارض بين
الجانبين هذه الرساله التي وجهت اليوم
للبيت الابيض كيف يمكن ان يرد عليها البيت
الابيض بالايام المقبله خصوصا اذا ما كان
هناك ضغط بموضوع يعني افراج عن رهينه
اولا وغيرها خطوه تصعيديه بامتياز ليس فقط
البيت الابيض لكن ايضا الكونجرس ووزاره
الخارجيه لكن لا اعتقد هناك من سال
بالواقع سؤال مشابه اليوم في الاجازه
الصحفي مع جون كاربي بانه هل ربما مقاده
بريتني جراينر التي تم اطلاق سراح روسي
كان يسمى بتاجر الموت في كان محكوم عليه
بسنوات طويله في الولايات المتحده يشجع
روسيا على اعتقال صحفيين امريكيين او
مواطنين امريكيين مقابل مقايضتين فقال
باننا لا نستطيع ان يعني ان نجيب على هذا
السؤال لاننا لسنا في وضع
يسمح لنا تحليل ماذا يفكر فيه الرئيس
بوتين او حتى المخابرات الروسيه لكن اعتقد
بانه هذه موقف يعرض هذه الاداره مره اخرى
لموقف صعب جدا كيف يمكن ان تطالب باطلاق
سراح طبعا مواطن امريكي قد يحكم لعشرين
عاما وهو صحفي ليس فقط مواطن امريكي وهل
تستطيع الاداره ان بالفعل تفرج عن اي روسي
تطلبه روسيا في مقايده لهذا الصحفي لنذكر
ايضا بان هناك مواطن امريكي اخر وهو لحتى
الان لم يطلق سراحه وايضا اتهمت روسيا
بالتجسس والولايات المتحده تقول بانه هذا
عاري عن الصحه وغير صحيح ورفضت مقايده حتى
ربما تستخدم حاليا ربما تستخدم لاحقا لا
نعرف لكنها بالفعل ازمه جديده بين واشنطن
شكرا لك ناديه البلبيسي مديره مكتب
العربيه في واشنطن على هذه الرساله
وقع الرئيس الروسي مرسوما بشان التجنيد
الاجباري للروس في الربيع وحسب المرسوم
فعلى المواطنين الروس الذين تتراوح
اعمارهم بين 18 الى سبعه الى 27 عاما
التقدم للتجنيد في الخدمه العسكريه بدايه
من ابريل وهو مرسوم يستهدف 147 الف شخص
وقالت تاس انه تم استدعاء 120 الف شخص
للخدمه العسكريه في الخليفه الماضي
كشف تقرير للمعهد الملكي للخدمات المتحده
في بريطانيا ان روسيا جندت شبكه عملاء
سريين في اوكرانيا قبل بدء الحرب حيث ما
زالت بعض هذه الشبكات تعمل حتى يومنا هذا
فلنتابع
شبكه من العملاء السريين نشرتهم روسيا في
اوكرانيا قبل الحرب هذه الشبكه ما تزال
تعمل حتى اليوم وتشكل تدفقا ثابتا من
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه كيف اعتقلت الاف
الاشخاص منذ بدايه الحرب بتهمه التعاون مع
روسيا وفقا لتقرير للمعهد الملكي للخدمات
المتحده موسكو اسست شبكات وجندت كثيرين
عبر الخداع فبينما يعتقد البعض من هؤلاء
المجندين الاوكرانيين في مناطق النزاع
بانهم يخدمون بلدهم افعالهم تعود بالنفع
لروسيا بغير قصد
انتقاده الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
علنا في روسيا يعتبر حدثا نادرا وتحديدا
اذا كان من مؤيد وفي حال ثبتت ادانتهم
بتهمه اهانه الدوله الروسيه او جيشها او
اهانه بوتين نفسه يواجهون غرامات وحتى
عقوبه السجن وفق دستور البلاد هذا القانون
تصدر المشهد بعد تسريب مكالمات لاثنين من
ابرز الشخصيات الداعمه لبوتين تصفه باوصاف
مشينه المكالمه المزعومه بلغت مدتها خمس
وثلاثين دقيقه سربتها صحيفه ديلي ميل
البريطانيه وتناقلتها وسائل اعلام
اوكرانيه وفي المقطع الصوتي يمكن سماع صوت
للسناتور الروسيه السابق فرهاد احمدوف
والمنتج الموسيقي البارز يوسف بريكوزين
ينتقدان بوتين بقسوه وتحدث المنتج
الموسيقي عن الخسائر الروسيه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه
هو انه على بوتين سحب قواته من اوكرانيا
والاستسلام قائلا بان بوتين اقحم نفسه في
الامر ليرد عليه احمد وفق قائلا انه للاسف
سيمر وقت طويل قبل ان يقرر بوتين سحب
الجيوش من اوكرانيا مضيفا بان الحكومه
الروسيه
دمرتهم ودمرت الاطفال ومستقبل البلاد
ومصير كل الشعب الروسي ومنذ تسريب
المكالمه مشاهدينا حللت العديد من المنافذ
الاوكرانيه والروسيه المستقله تسجيل
الصوتي ووجدوا انه يعود الى الرابع
والعشرين من يناير الماضي بدوره ادعى
بان التسجيل مزيف والى ان الانترنت تحول
الى مكب نفايات كبير يمكن استخدامه لتشويه
سمعه الناس واكد انه يكن الاحترام الكبير
لبوتين وانه رغم خوفه من العواقب لن يفر
من موسكو لكن بالمقابل
احمدوف لم يعلق على التسريب فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
بعدما وصفه بالجيد بشكل مخيف اله ماسك
ينقلب على الذكاء الاصطناعي تشات ويطالب
بوقف تطويره لانه يشكل خطر كبير على
المجتمعات كلام ماسك جاء عبر رساله مفتوحه
وقع عليها اكثر من الف شخص دعوا فيها الى
التوقف لمده سته اشهر عن تطوير انظمه اقوى
من روبوت الدردشه
الذي اطلقته شركه اوبن ال في الاونه
الاخيره رساله ماسك الصادره عن معهد
طرحت عده اسئله ابرز هذه الاسئله هل يجب
ان نسمح للالات باغراق قنواتنا الاعلاميه
بالدعايه والكذب هل ينبغي ان نطور عقولا
غير بشريه قد تفوقنا عددا وذكاء وتتفوق
علينا وتحل محلنا وتقول ايضا الرساله
الموجهه لتشات انه لا يجب تفويض قرارات
هذه لقاده تكنولوجيا غير منتخبين والتاكد
من ان اثار هذه القرارات ستكون ايجابيه
وان مخاطرها ستكون تحت السيطره وهنا لابد
من الاشاره مشاهدينا بان ماسك هو من مؤسسي
شركات اوبن ال الرائده وشركه تسلا
للسيارات تستخدم كما هو معروف ومعلوم
الذكاء الصناعي في انظمه القياده الذاتيه
روبوت الدردشه
اثار مخاوف المشرعين الامريكيين ايضا
وتساءلوا عن تاثيره على الامن القومي
والتعليم والحكومه البريطانيه هنا كشفت
النقاب عن مقترحات لوضع اطار تنظيم قابل
للتكيف حول الذكاء الصناعي الشركه الام
اليتشات جيبي لم تعلق على كافه المخاوف
والتساؤلات متسلحه طبعا بالنجاح الذي
حققته بفتره قصيره بعدما وصل عدد
المستخدمين لتطبيق مئه مليون مستخدم نشط
شهريا
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر عن مخاطر هذا التطوير السريع
ينضم الينا من
الدكتور احمد بن نافع استاذ الهندسه وامن
الشبكات في الولايات المتحده استاذ يعني
انت من الموقعين على هذه العريضه لماذا
السؤال جيد جدا الخوف مش من اللي موجود
الان اللي هو
اربعه الخوف من اللي جاي اديك فكره عن
الموضوع هذا المعلومات اللي عندنا في وادي
السلك انه الجيل الجديد اللي هو خمسه فيه
في مشاكل كبيره حتحصل فيه مثلا ان انت
مثلا الجيل الثالث اللي هو رقم ثلاثه
دربوها على 175 مليار معلومه الاربعه على
تريليون خمسه الان وصل لمرحله هو يختار
المعلومات اللي يدرب نفسها عليها فهذه هي
مصدر القلق الان
اليوم
شهاده وقرات الكثير من التقارير تتحدث عن
مخاوف اخلاقيه عن مخاوف مجتمعيه عن مخاوف
حتى سياسيه بان تتحكم قله من قاده
التكنولوجيا بالعالم كله بارائه بفكره بكل
شيء لماذا يعني هل ممكن ان نشرح هذه
المخاوف لو سمحت
هذه نقطه جيده جدا هذه من ضمن اللي ورد في
الرساله انه الاشخاص هذول اللي موجودين في
مبنى متواضع في سان فرانسيسكو
بيتحكموا في اتجاه التكنولوجيا الان
تقرير الاخير جولد من انه 300 مليون وظيفه
حتفقد بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي نسبه 18% من
الوظائف في العالم في امريكا 25% بيفقد
عملهم بسبب الذكاء الاصطناعي هذه من ناحيه
العمل من ناحيه الاقتصاد من الناحيه
الاخلاقيه المعلومات المزيفه
والفيديوهات اللي هي مزيفه ينشروها عن
طريق الانترنت ومين اللي بيقوم بتكوينها
بعملها بيكون الذكاء الاصطناعي اضافه
للاشياء كثيره نفسيه ممكن تصيب الناس من
استخدامهم لهذه لهذه الجهه
المستثمرين الاساسيين اليوم بالذكاء
الاصطناعي هم مايكروسوفت كل الشركات
التكنولوج المعروفه وبالتالي هم نفسهم
سيبقون مسيطرين على السوق للمستقبل ماذا
يعني ذلك خصوصا ان التشريعات بالولايات
المتحده حتى الساعه هي غير قادره على ضبط
يعني وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي احدثت
فوضى كبيره خصوصا عند الجيل الجديد
هذه نقطه جيده جدا ايضا من ناحيه
من ناحيهم انهم يتحكموا في اتجاه
التكنولوجيا الان او اي شيء يحصل من هذه
التكنولوجيا اليوم في منظمه متخصصه في
الذكاء الاصطناعي قدمت شكوى ضد اوبن اي اي
على انهم هم يعني خرقوا قوانين الخصوصيه
وحصلوا على معلومات من غير اذن فهذه فهذه
هي الخطه الاولى لهم لكن مثل ما تفضلتي
مايكروسوفت جوجل هم الان دخلوا في يعني في
سباق محموم على اساس انه مين يكون الرائد
في هذا المجال شكرا لك دكتور احمد بن نافع
استاذ الهندسه وامن الشبكات الالكترونيه
على هذه المداخله
[موسيقى]
اكدت مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
للشؤون الشرق الاوسط بربراليف في رد على
سؤال للعربيه اكدت ان الولايات المتحده
ستتابع ما اذا كانت ايران ستلتزم بانهاء
الحرب في اليمن مشيره الى ان ايران تقود
حربا بالوكاله في المنطقه كما اكدت على ان
واشنطن تتمنى ان ينعكس الاتفاقي الايراني
بشكل ايجابي على لبنان وفي تصريحات اخرى
دعت المسؤوله الامريكيه اللبنانيين الى
الاسراع بانتخاب رئيس حول ليبيا اكدت انه
يجب ان تغادر كل القوات الاجنبيه البلاد
وخصوصا قوات فاجنر الروسيه
اكدت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للعربيه عن التقارب الايراني السعودي بان
فرنسا تدعم الحوار بين السعوديه وايران
وتؤيد كل مبادره يمكنها ان تساهم بشكل
ملموس في خفض التوتر وتعزيز الاستقرار
والامن الاقليميه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الكاميرا العربيه ترصد الجهود الصحيه
السعوديه المقدمه للمعتمرين في الحرم
المكي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد روسيا والصين ودول اخرى
فتحت النار على الدولار الامريكي حرب
اقتصاديه تسعى الى كسر هيمنه الدولار
والبحث عن بدائل له في التبادلات التجاريه
من خلال العملات المحليه كالروبه للروسي
وليوان الصيني المزيد مشاهدينا في تقرير
التالي
بندلعوا حروبه عملات من وقت لاخر يكون
الطرف المحارب فيها هو الدولار واطراف
القتال متعدده اخرها الصين والبرازيل بعد
اعلانهما تخليهما عن الدولار الامريكي
اتفاق يتيح للصين ثاني عملاق تجاري واكبر
منافس للهيمنه الاقتصاديه الامريكيه
والبرازيل اكبر اقتصاد في امريكا
اللاتينيه وشركه التجاريه الاكبر للصين
اجراء صفقاتهما التجاريه الهائله مباشره
واستبدالها بالعمله المحليه
فالتبادل التجاري بينهما قدر ب150 مليار
دولار في العام الماضي فقط
على الجانب الاخر حرب اقتصاديه تدور راحها
في ساحه اخرى هي روسيا والمحارب فيها هو
الدولار الامريكي ايضا
موسكو لم تتخذ فقط من اوكرانيا ساحه حرب
لها بل بالتوازي استخدمت اسواق العالم ارض
حرب اخرى سلع روسيا فيها ضد امريكا ليس
عسكريا بل تجاري تجاريا اتخذت موسكو سلاح
الروبل للحد من استخدام الدولار في
معاملاتها الدوليه حتى الطاقه كانت احد
اسلحه روسيا الفعاله في مارس الماضي اصدرت
موسكو مرسوما يقضي ببيع الغاز والنفط
للدول غير الصديقه حصرا بالروبل
كما انها عززت من علاقاتها الخارجيه خاصه
مع الصين الصديق التاريخي لها تجمعهما
مساعا لم تعد خفيه تاسيس نظام دولي جديد
لا يعتمد على الدولار كعمله رئيسيه في
التبادلات التجاريه والماليه اما الهند
الشريك الوطيد لروسيا فسبق ان اعلنت العام
الماضي عن اتفاق ثنائي باستخدام عملتيهما
المحليتين في التبادل التجاري بينهما
الخزانه الامريكيه ترى ان كسر هيمنه
الدولار امر صعب جدا فيما اخرون يحذرون من
تداعياته
فمحاولات اضعاف الدولار قد تعني نظاما
نقديا اكثر تشتتا ومجاميع تجاريه منفصله
بتكتلات عملات صغيره روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
في مكه المكرمه تعمل قوات الطوارئ الخاصه
برئاسه امن الدوله باداره وتنظيم الحشود
داخل ساحات المسجد الحرام طوال ايام شهر
رمضان لضمان سلامه انسيابيه الدخول وخروج
المعتمرين والمصلين والزوار وتقديم
الخدمات الانسانيه فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
طوق امني لقوات الطوارئ الخاصه بالعاصمه
المقدسه داخل ساحات المسجد الحرام لضبط
عمليه تدفقات البشريه للمعتمرين والمصلين
والزوار بعد تشغيل الحرم المكي بكامل
الطاقه الاستيعابيه بموسم رمضان هذا العام
كانياتها البشريه والاليه بالاضافه الى
جاهزيتها وجاهزيه جميع الوحدات لخدمه ضيوف
الرحمن هذه الخدمه التي نتشرف بها كما
تشرف بها جميع القطاعات الامنيه والخدميه
في خدمه ضيوف الرحمن اداره الحشود
وحمايتها هي المهمه الاولى لهؤلاء الرجال
الذين يقفون جنبا الى جنب لتنظيم وتفكيك
الكثافات البشريه وتقديم الخدمات
الانسانيه قوات الطوار خاصه برئاسه امن
الدوله احد قطاعات رئاسه الامن الدوله
المشاركه في هذه المهمه وتقوم باداره
الحشود البشريه في الساحه الجنوبيه من
المسجد الحرام اضافه الى توفير الحمايه
الامنيه لملوك ورؤساء الدول اثناء اداء
مناسك العمره بالاضافه الى جاهزيه وحداتها
الخاصه للقيام بالمهام النوعيه وقت الحاجه
وللدعم والاسناد في اي موقف او حدث يشهد
الحرم المكي منذ بدايه شهر رمضان اعدادا
ضخمه من المعتمرين والمصلين مما ضاعف
اعمال رجال الامن بمختلف القطاعات لحفظ
سلامه وامن الزائرين ومسانده القطاعات
العامله من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
توصل وزاره الصحه السعوديه جهودها بتقديم
خدماتها الصحيه والعلاجيه المتميزه لضيوف
الرحمن وقاصدين بيت الحرم ويعد مستشفى
اجياد لطوارئ بمكه المكرمه المجاور للحرم
المكي الشريف من ابرز مرافق الصحه التي
خصصتها لتوفير الرعايه الصحيه والطبيه
العلاجيه لهم اذ يقدم المستشفى خدمات
للمرضى والمراجعين على مدى اليوم لاستقبال
الحالات الطارئه من المرضى او المصابين في
الحرم والمنطقه المركزيه المحيطه بالحرم
المكي الشريف للمزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه
الخدمات ومن المستشفى تحديدا ينضم الينا
من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي مراسل
العربيه سلطان كيف هي الصوره من هناك
اهلا بك راوي واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه من داخل مستشفى اجياد للطوارئ هذا
المستشفى الذي يقع في المنطقه المركزيه
التابعه للحرم المكي ويعمل على خدمه
المعتمرين والمصلين طوال ايام الشهر رمضان
نتحدث على هذا المستشفى الذي يتكون من 52
السرير منها السره للتنويم والعنايه
المركزه وكذلك السر للعمليات كذلك نتحدث
على استعدادات كبيره تعمل عليها وزاره
الصحه السعوديه ونتحدث كذلك خدمات طبيه
مقدمه تعمل على مدار الساعه لكافه المرضى
وزوار المسجد الحرام لذلك مزيد من
التفاصيل ينضم الى الدكتور عبد الرحمن
اماني نائب المدير التنفيذي لمستشفى اجياد
والحرم وكذلك مراكز التابعه في الحرم
المكي على شاشه العربيه بدايه نريد ان
نعرف حجم الاستعداد وكذلك نوعيه موجوده
وكذلك نتحدث ايضا عن ابرز الحاله التي تم
التعامل معها طبعا رفع جاهزيه المرافق
الصحيه تابعه لتجمع الصحي بمكه المكرمه
مثلا مستشفى ايجاد للطوارئ
بسعه سريريه 52 سرير عنايه مركزه وطوارئ
مدعومه باحدث التقنيات الاسرائيليه لسكتات
الدماغيه والعنايه المركزه وذلك بالتعاون
مع مستشفى الافتراضي وكذلك تم تفعيل
مستشفى الحرم للطوارئ والذي يتسع ب 34
سرير عنايه مركزه وطارق ايضا
نوعيه التي تم التعامل معه كم عدد الحالات
التامه تم التعامل معها من بدايه الشهر
الى اليوم عدد الحالات اللي تعاملنا معاها
بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك لعام 1444 يتجاوز
الخمسه الاف حاله الى الان نوعيه الحالات
نوعيتها غالبا بتكون حالات حرجه واذا كانت
تحتاج اي تقدم مثلا حاجات جراحيه
يتم حالتها بشكل مباشر بالتعاون مع
مستشفيات التابعه للتجمع الصحي ثنائي
جولتي في المستشفى لاحظت انه في منطقه
بيضاء وصفراء وحمراء ايش المناطق هذه في
المستشفى المنطقه الصفراء مخصصه للحالات
غير معديه والمنطقه الخضراء للحالات
المعده التنفسيه غالبا نطق البيضاء بتكون
امتداد لاحدى المنطقتين في حال امتلائها
طيب لو ممكن تعطينا بس لمحه بسيطه عن ابرز
الامكانيات الموجوده كمختبرات واشعه طبعا
المستشفى مدعومه ومزوده بجميع
الاحتياجات من اشعه تشخيصيه ومختبرات
تشخيصيه كذلك ورعايه صيدليه صيدلانيه
بالاضافه الى الخدمات الطبيه المسانده
الاخرى
يعني هذه كان ابرز التفاصيل والارقام
والاحصائيات والامكانيات الموجوده في
مستشفى اجياد للطوارئ هنا في المنطقه
المركزيه بالحرم المكي تتحدث الامكانيات
كبيره تعمل الى وزاره الصحه السعوديه
وكافه القطاعات العامله هنا في المسجد
الحرام لتقديم وتسهيل على كافه المعتمرين
والمصلين نعم شكرا لك سلطان سلم بمراسل
العربيه حدثنا من مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]
حذر خبراء الارصاد الجويه من ان سلسله من
العواصف مصحوبه باعاصير قاتله من المتوقع
ان تضرب اجزاء من الغرب الاوسط والجنوب في
امريكا خلال الاسبوعين المقبلين وخاصه
الجمعه ذلك اليوم الذي وصفه الخبراء بيوم
الجمعه المميت باعتباره احد اسوا الايام
التي ستمر على البلاد وقالت هيئه الارصاد
الجويه الامريكيه ان 16 مليون شخص يعيشون
في المنطقه الاكثر عرضه للخطر فيما يجب
على اكثر من 66 مليون شخص ان يكونوا في
حاله تاهب ليوم الجمعه
هذا وتسببت مشاهدينا فيضانات في مقاطعه بي
كاليفورنيا بدمار كبير بالطرقات وغمرت
المحاصيل الزراعيه تحت الماء بالكامل بعد
اعصار ضرب الولايه فلنتابع
[موسيقى]
اعلنت السلطات في مدينه تايموند الامريكيه
خروج قطار شحن عن مساره وقد اشتعلت
النيران
الذي كان ينقل عددا من خزانات تحتوي على
الايثانول وامرت السلطات السكان القريبين
من موقع الحادث باخلاء منازلهم في حين لم
تعلن السلطات عن وقوع اصابات او ضحايا
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
بسبب الخلافات بين الدعم السريع والجيش
تاجيل توقيع الاتفاق النهائي في السودان
بعد يوم هادئ عوده الاحتجاجات الى فرنسا
تمديدا بعنف الشرطه تجاه المتظاهرين مؤخرا
الخارجيه الروسيه تتهم مراسل جورنال
بالجاسوسيه والصحيفه تعتبرها ازمه
دبلوماسيه
انجاز
بعد استثمارات له بالمليارات الى ماسك
يطالب بايقاف تطوير الذكاء الاصطناعي حفظا
للوظائف
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
شكرا لحسن المتابعه واتمنى لكم نهايه
اسبوع جميله والان الى 360 مع الزميله
راويه راويه ماذا لديك مساء الخير اهلا بك
ليال سنتحدث طبعا عن احتجاز موسكو لاحد
صحفي وسطي
وتداعيات المستقبل التي قد يخلفها هذا
الاحتجاز وايضا فيروس ماربورج تفشي كبير
الان في غينيا
تنزانيا ايضا للاسف تفضل تابعينا
[موسيقى]